[ __ ] like the original one i think is
such a goddamn
gem of a game when you go to an arcade
you see i still think time crisis is
good and the only reason i could never
progress
too far in time crisis was because i
never had enough money yeah yeah so like
i think
once you get over that point of time
crisis where you've beaten it a few
times
you can beat the whole game at least
game one on one credit
like pretty good pretty easily yeah yeah
because you know you know when all the
bullshit's coming
and to me when i used to play because
like you know when you're when you would
go to an arcade right because we i would
stay in like france for like i don't
know two weeks at a time yeah my parents
would give me like two euros a day
maybe how did you complete the game the
first time which is what i wanted yeah
i've i've like no matter what i i have
always run out of money yeah i feel i
feel like the first time you played time
crisis if you only had like two credits
right yeah you could
maybe get past you know maybe up to like
stage two so this was like something
over like years
where it was like i would always like
see it in arcades and i would always
pick it up and then
maybe if i had two weeks i would play it
like every day for two weeks right
or i would like you know and as well i
got to the point where it
when when okay if you had your name on
the high score
all of them so i would go and try and
take all 10 slots when i would go
when i would go to like a vacation point
true again because i would be there for
like two weeks so i'm like oh what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna take every single
slot on this thing yeah but then i um
and so eventually what you could what i
would do is
i would be like if someone was gonna
play it i would just like i would just
chill out and i'd be like oh that's me
by the way and then they would be like
oh
yeah they would be like oh you want to
play with me i'm like hell yeah give me
your credit and
they'd give me a credit right and i
could just play you literally game the
system
no yeah but then but then it was
[ __ ] because some people uh some of
the systems when they pulled out the
plug at
night like it would wipe all the high
schools that was like my worst nightmare
because i would i would get the high
score
yeah you know feel real good i'd come
back the next day and i'm like
where is it where is my high school my
street cred
gone just like how did you prove that
that name was you though that's what i
want to know people just took your word
for it
um that's a good question how do they do
it i guess it's just the old system
right of just people just took your word
for it
i guess your whole system yeah i guess
the moment they i put the coin and i
started [ __ ] just destroying everyone
they'd be like i think it's him
it's you know this the old speed run
rules right like you don't need you
don't we don't need video proof we
trust that you say well because like if
you're a rookie right time
they'd go like this you know i would
just like so i would like get yeah
because the way right i learned right
i'm like wait the the normal way of
shooting so
if you i'm assuming most people who are
watching this have seen or played a time
crisis if you haven't it's the one where
you put your pedal down
on the thing yeah and then you pop out
to shoot that should be enough to let
you know i mean i assume if you've left
your house been an arcade or
anything or been bowling you've seen
this thing it's it's [ __ ] basically
it's the best arcane
uh arcade game you can play you don't
live in japan or yeah and i realized
right after a while i'm like right
if you're doing the whole like holding
it with two hands pointing shooting your
finger isn't fast enough and the way the
time crisis worked with points is that
you had to
like there would be this like a smash
combo right but when you
shot a character first there was like a
split second where you could keep
shooting them with bullets
to get more points and combo it so if
you shot someone once that's it you only
got like 10 points
you could unload like eight bullets into
one person so what you'd have to do is
when they would all pop up on screen you
have to get like max amount of points on
each person on screen right so i would
unload the whole mag into one character
so that's how you had to be like a man
just like discover turbo mode no yes
it was literally like imagine like you
know i literally just learned the
technique of like spamming this thing
like this i would like to twitch my hand
absolutely like
oh [ __ ] like and then i would do it for
everyone on the screen and so that way
no one came close to beating me in
school
yeah yeah and then i would remember the
points where like i think a time crisis
one or two there's a point where you get
a machine gun and if you you could like
juggle the cover
so that you could keep your combo even
while going in cover mm-hmm
so you could like juggle it to get an
absurd combo this man at age 10 is
optimizing games
so i remember this was when he had a
speech like literally like age 13 i was
doing this and then like it was like
yeah i mean
maxing time crisis yeah because i i
loved it and then you know then you
start playing time crisis
three and four so two was nice two is
when they introduced like sorry i'm
going too in depth so time crash is one
all you had was the pistol yeah and you
could do boom time crashes too they
started introducing like weird [ __ ] like
machine gun grenade
shotgun you're like all right whatever
cool time guys is three is where they
start getting [ __ ] weird with it and
they start introducing all this dumb
[ __ ] now i'm like seven
yeah and it's just garbage like it's
[ __ ] game where you just get [ __ ]
shot it's like it's like house of the
dead
well you were playing five the other day
and you said five was all right it's
okay but like they introduced like they
i feel like they they did what house of
the dead did
like where house of the dead was an
amazing arcade game one was
pretty challenging two was quite
difficult and they started adding a few
things that were like
that's true that's cheeky that and three
onwards they just started adding [ __ ]
that would just kill you yeah like
unless you literally like perfect
headshot yeah everything
yeah because you've played it right yeah
and there's times where you're literally
hitting everything on house of the dead
and it's just like it
this game [ __ ] sucks dick [ __ ] this
game you just took my money and i don't
like it i'm a good guy
you're literally you're literally that
kid you know in persona 5. you know the
kid in the arcade yeah
teaches you the gun moves that's
literally i'm i'm just sitting here and
i'm i'm just thinking i don't think i've
heard connor talk more passionately
about something
like since i've been friends with him
chris
is the best game and i also had it on
ps2
so that also helped wow that was the
next stage up right so i had i had time
gracious 2
on the ps2 and so when i went to the
arcade i was like it's just like the
simulations
like i've been waiting to use that meme
it was literally like that because i was
like i already know exactly when is the
optimization
i like i know all the levels off by
[ __ ] matrix
well that was the thing as well it's
like because because you were like you
were broke and you didn't have credits
you i would legit like
it was the same thing with metal slug i
would be like i would just go up to the
kids and i'm like
hey i'm really [ __ ] good at this if
you give me a credit i'll help you get
really far and then you'll be like oh
okay sure
because then it was a win-win because
even though i was doing all the work
they felt like they were getting an
extra 15 minutes of fun where they would
have got two yeah you know what i mean i
mean
that's that's the thing right where you
know that i mean i guess arcade games
were the original pay to win yeah
because that's not like like i never met
a single person who had completed time
crisis because how the [ __ ]
does any kid my age complete time price
yeah i would i would like
i would like have a fit in my head if i
even got hit once in time crisis
after a while because i was like i knew
where they all should have been coming
this man is trying to know hit time
well it was like it was so fun because
after like you said right you're not
supposed to
the games weren't designed for you to
play it this much yeah but this is also
why they started
upping the difficulty of arcades because
people would just sit there all day
yeah and complete games on one dollar
and get 30 minutes when they should have
been getting two minutes
and so that's why they started upping
you know now it's like all the arcade
games like
even the ones that used to be like
pretty fair and used to feel good i just
[ __ ] like yeah
like the mario kart arcade game now [ __ ]
that game sucks you get one race
it's shitty you know like if you were
doing like daytona back in the day
if you were [ __ ] good at that game
you kept to get you kept playing because
you kept getting to the checks points
yeah
right but now it's like you get one race
[ __ ] off that was three dollars it's
like
no just because you got to take a
picture with me and put it on the
character you think that's enough to
keep me happy
no [ __ ] off mario this is [ __ ] yeah
although to be fair every time i see
that and i'm with like three other
people i'm like they always want to play
it
you play it and then every time you play
it you're like all right
because people want to play because it's
mario kart and then it plays worse than
the actual mario kart yeah how do they
do that it's supposed to be better what
the [ __ ]
i'm so passionate about because arcade
games suck now
va the fall of arcade games there's some
good verizon for the horizon
actually you know the absolute state
little market
you know i think we spoke about it on
the podcast four but typing of the dead
in uh i think i hope it isn't in the one
that closed down because one of the game
centers in akihabara closed down
right and only one of them had typing of
the dead yeah which you don't know what
typing of that is google it
uh yeah that's good um the jojo battle
royale is okay
yeah it's like a it's like an unreal
engine mod that's it's kind of [ __ ] yeah
yeah
there's no real arcade games now
actually the mech
we don't know what it's called but here
it is so we know what it looks like
you get to pilot a mac like you
literally sit in the cockpit
you put a seat belt on and there's like
uh gas pedals
drift pedals yeah and it's like 4d
cinema so it actually yeah it moves
it moves as you are flying about so you
are literally
as close to a mecca pilot as you can
possibly be and it's got ranked pvp so
you literally
you literally like you all jump in the
max with the boys and you can pvp
against other people literally capture
the flag
yeah yeah and it's like domination from
pod i think yeah yeah yeah and yeah you
literally like
it's so fun cause when you smack down
that thrust and drift pedal
the [ __ ] the chair jumps back yeah it
jumps back and then it's like
like yeah like uh was it like when the
chains going up on the roller coaster
like drifting yeah yeah it's so good
like drifting in the end just firing
missiles at the same time
i'm just dealing with that with the boys
you know like switch out the reload the
other one as you're shooting
oh my god yeah yeah we're trying to
knock it off this player yeah yeah you
come to japan you've got to check this
this is like everyone says rhythm games
no this is the best arcade game i've
played in japan
far none yeah i believe it's is it sega
yeah it's saying yeah it's it's i've
already seen it in a few
are like sort of round one and i saw it
in sega but like yeah
it's actually insane i think it's is it
two dollars or three dollars a play it's
like yeah
two dollars not enough yeah two dollars
a player i think but
one play can last you you know like 15
minutes 15 20 minutes
i'd happily play like pay like five
pounds if it was like in the uk
yeah because my god you get to pilot a
mecca that's so cool
oh god i don't even know what's going on
because i can't read what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] they're saying yeah like i
yeah i love it it's so funny i mean i
can read what they're saying but i don't
give a [ __ ]
it's not important to me